io faccio l'agricoltura contemporanea
uso un sacco di tecnologia per coltivare
in maniera sostenibile un sacco di
tecnologia per coltivare l'insalata
perfetta anche le altre cose Però non
solo l'insalata però vorrei partire
dall'inizio e spiegarvi perché secondo
me la tecnologia è fondamentale per
ripensare l'agricoltura Ci sono alcuni
fatti in 40 anni abbiamo consumato il
33% del terreno coltivabile disponibile
sul pianeta un terzo un 40 anni ancora
il 70% delle risorse idriche disponibili
sul pianeta è consumato ogni anno
dall'agricoltura industriale
dall'agricoltura intensiva quella che si
fa un po' in tutto il mondo
ancora
questo grafico rappresenta il volume
d'affari delle aziende che
commercializzano farmaci negli ultimi 40
anni del secolo scorso poi hanno anche
smesso di tracciare la curva
ancora il cambiamento climatico Vabbè
tutti tutti ne parlano piove sempre di
meno piove tantissimo Non ci sono più le
mezze stagioni Sta di fatto che se vuoi
combinate questi pochi elementi questi
pochi numeri con gli 8 miliardi di
persone che pochi giorni fa siamo
diventati su questo pianeta capite come
sta di fatto che dobbiamo ripensare in
maniera radicale questa agricoltura
perché così come oggi non è più
sostenibile su larga Scala
questo del Vertical Farming è uno dei
pensieri che sono stati fatti per
rifondare all'agricoltura non è per
niente Nelle nuove È un'idea che ha
almeno 20 anni un'idea che risale alla
fine del secolo scorso ed è l'idea di un
professore di New York professor che
Immagina come l'agricoltura possa
diventare verticale usiamo termini
italiani che forse è più semplice Questa
è una Vertical Farm Questo è un orto
verticale Questo è uno che realizziamo
uno degli Orti che realizziamo noi per
me è una scatola magica È una scatola
magica in cui riusciamo a ricostruire in
maniera molto precisa le condizioni
ideali per le piante Il nutrimento
perfetto il clima perfetto le mettiamo
al sicuro Dai patogeni e loro ci
ricompenseno perché per 365 giorni
l'anno sempre a stagionalità ci regalano
il massimo del loro potenziale
Beh io potrei passare una serata intera
molto più del tempo che mi hai concesso
raccontarvi tutti i vantaggi di questa
agricoltura però ci sono almeno tre cose
che credo valga la pena di sottolineare
la prima non si usano Assolutamente
pesticidi si va oltre il residuo Zero in
queste agricoltura perché semplicemente
non servono le piante sono protette sono
all'interno della nostra scatola magica
il secondo vantaggio consumiamo il 95%
in meno della dell'acqua che si utilizza
Con l'agricoltura tradizionale il 95% in
meno il terzo vantaggio sostanziale che
risparmiamo tantissimo suono il 90%, e
in quello che liberiamo possiamo pensare
di ripiantare alberi o di riproporre la
biodiversità che spesso l'agricoltura
industriale Mette in discussione
Sta di fatto che con tutti questi
vantaggi ci potremmo aspettare che
l'agricoltura verticale sia ubiquitaria
30 ettari di Vertical Farm in tutto il
pianeta alla fine del 2020 per chi non è
non ha familiarità con le misure
dell'Agricoltura ci sono 500.000 ettari
di Serre nel pianeta e 50 milioni di
ettari di coltivazione pieno campo
Quindi vedete che quel piccolo pallino
che rappresenta le Vertical Farm in
realtà non racconta la storia di un
successo tutt'altro ci deve essere un
problema da qualche parte c'è
sicuramente un grosso problema Il
problema è il più semplice Il problema è
che i conti non tornano questa è
un'agricoltura costosissima è
un'agricoltura complicatissima e quello
che succede È che alla fine il suo unico
utilizzo è quello di produrre
costosissime insalatine che finiscono
sullo scaffale del supermercato a prezzi
molto molto più alti dei prodotti
biologici in questo posizionamento rende
l'agricoltura verticale uno standard di
alta qualità ma di nicchia un fenomeno
assolutamente limitato
Qual è la sfida la sfida di aggiustare
il Vertical farmi di trovare la formula
per
rendere questa agricoltura superiore per
molti aspetti più democratiche e più
accessibile in ultima analisi il
prodotto nell'agricoltura verticale deve
competere quel prodotto coltivato in
maniera convenzionale
quello che abbiamo fatto nel negli
ultimi sette anni e di capire come
risolvere questa questa sfida e
l'abbiamo fatto nell'equivalente del
nord-est d'Italia della garage di
Silicon Valley cioè il capannone grigio
anonimo nella zona industriale di
Pordenone e 7 anni di Ricerca e Sviluppo
sono fondamentali perché il problema va
risolto alla base noi diciamo da zero
per questo motivo per cui l'azienda
l'abbiamo chiamata così va reinventata
la tecnologia non si possono comperare
pezzi di tecnologia esistente questo
Sarebbe facile però poi quello che
succederebbe è che ancora una volta i
conti non tornerebbero quindi si tratta
di ricostruire una tecnologia e di farlo
se volete in quello che io penso essere
il posto ideale per ripensare
l'agricoltura verticale che è l'Italia e
vi spiego perché vi spiego perché
secondo me ci sono gli ingredienti
giusti per farlo qui
Prima di tutto l'agronomo
l'agricoltore contemporaneo è un
personaggio un po' strano perché ha in
sé tante personalità è un po' un
agronomo è un po' un biologo però al
tempo stesso è anche un ingegnere e
anche uno sviluppatore software e Qui si
tratta di
contaminare le competenze si tratta di
fare un po' quello che si faceva nel
rinascimento nelle botteghe nelle
botteghe nelle botteghe d'arte dove si
imparavano i mestieri sono mestieri
nuovi questi qui ma non basta la
competenza qui serve anche qualcosa di
più tangibile fisico questi sono grandi
impianti industriali di migliaia di
metri quadrati e c'è una dimensione
manifatturiera Beh l'Italia è ancora una
grandissima economia manifattura la
seconda ed Europa In Italia c'è la
filiera del metallo cioè la filiera
della plastica cioè la filiera della
gomma in Italia c'è la meccanica di
precisione cioè l'elettronica In Italia
c'è l'automazione industriale i nostri
Orti verticali Sono delle grandi
macchine automatiche che coltivano quasi
da sole Se volete e poi c'è
moltissimo software c'è moltissimo
software che fa un po' da collante per
tutta questa dimensione fisica e in
questi Orti verticali ci sono tutte le
parole chiave se volete del futuro
prossimo cioè l'intelligenza artificiale
c'è L'analisi dei dati ci sono un po'
tutte queste competenze e in Italia
Abbiamo del talento anche quando si
tratta di digitale Forse talvolta
sottovalutato rispetto ad altre economie
sulla carta più evolute
poi qui si parla di cibo Noi siamo
italiani siamo credibili io quando stavo
all'estero venivo sempre interpellato
quando si trattava di chiedere un
consiglio per il ristorante Da quando si
parla di food si parla di alimentazione
agli italiani sono credibili sono
ascoltati e possiamo usarla possiamo
fare leva su questa credibilità e poi in
questi Orti verticali c'è tantissima
ricerca Ne abbiamo impiegato anni a
togliere la Terra da sotto le piante che
sembra quasi un'eresia però le piante
stanno meglio senza terra eh vivono
belle felici e sta di fatto che la
qualità della ricerca italiana c'è tutta
è riconosciuta in Europa spesso manca il
trasferimento tecnologico che è un'altra
cosa Ma ci torniamo tra Pochi istanti
bene poi in Italia c'è anche un altro
ingrediente fondamentale che è il
talento cioè il talento e la capacità
del dei talenti di pensare
trasversalmente Questa è l'unica cosa
orizzontale della mia presentazione la
capacità di di guardare a
alla fine vicine e con curiosità capire
come evolvere la propria competenza
verso un territorio così una terra di
confine inesplorate
c'è di fatto la capacità di costruire lo
strumento Noi pensiamo di averla avuta
nella capacità di costruire uno
strumento che assicura qualità che
assicura produttività che assicura un
costo ridotto di produzione il minimo
impatto ambientale è anche un sistema
costruttivo molto veloce Noi pensiamo di
aver risolto l'equazione di
sostenibilità per questi Orti verticali
però quello che abbiamo dovuto fare è
investirci ancora una volta abbiamo
dovuto dimostrare che non era
sufficiente la tecnologia Ma dimostrare
che quella tecnologia poteva anche
diventare un grande impianto industriale
e questo è quello che abbiamo costruito
abbiamo rigenerato vicino a Brescia sul
lago d'Iseo è un grande sito è una ex
industria tessile che è stata convertita
a grande orto verticale e che è
alimentata dall'energia del fiume la
centrale idroelettrica che vedete lì al
centro dell'immagine alimenta
direttamente il nostro orto verticale Ed
è l'unica soluzione è possibile per
rendere questa agricoltura veramente
sostenibile ma non è solo insalata si
può andare ben oltre insalata e secondo
me qui c'è proprio il segreto forse
l'insalata è un po' troppo poco per
tutta questa tecnologia Allora vediamo
cosa ci si può fare Ci si possono fare
le fragole anche questo forse è un po'
troppo però cominciamo a guardare altre
applicazioni Questa è una vivaistica di
nuova generazione Queste sono barbatelle
vengono coltivate da aziende famose in
quest'area in maniera tradizionale noi
possiamo combinare le nostre competenze
con queste aziende per reinventare la
vivaistica possiamo coltivare la
cannabis ad uso medico questo è una
materia prima farmaceutica che deve
essere coltivata in un ambiente protetto
possiamo coltivare dei biomateriali
questo è micelio la parte bianca del
fungo che viene trasformata in materiale
che è equivalente alla pelle
possiamo usare le piante per produrre
delle sostanze utili nel mondo
farmaceutico le piante come biorettori
piccole fabbriche molecolari possiamo
fare ancora di più possiamo darle la
nostra competenza di Agricoltori
contemporanee agli architetti e
costruire una nuova architettura che
fonde le competenze di due eccellenze
italiane
vi lascio con un pensiero io credo che
questo dell'Agricoltura
verticale sia un nuovo settore di
eccellenza in cui l'Italia può
giocarsela come la moda come
l'arredamento come il design Beh questa
onda d'innovazione non ce la possiamo
giocare alla protagonista in tutto il
mondo e io penso che sia una sfida forse
troppo ambiziosa per una piccola azienda
come la nostra Però noi possiamo agire
in maniera Corale possiamo mettere
assieme le filiere industriali possiamo
mettere assieme la ricerca un
trasferimento tecnologico più efficiente
possiamo trovare un supporto anche della
politica forse e se agiamo a livello di
sistema questo secondo me diventa un
futuro tutt'altro che remoto e utop
questo è il futuro possibile nel breve
termine un futuro da coltivare assieme e
io vi ringrazio molto
[Applauso]